hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to the travesty that is
genital jousting we don't know why we're
here again but you guys demanded it
question mark I'm sure they did who why
would you not gone so we're gonna do the
other unlocks involuntary oh you want to
stay inside the ring whoa whoa wait wait
bill chill chill [ __ ] mark out of here
Oh
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Laughter]
I don't feel good about this basically
no matter what happens
[Music]
[Laughter]
why did I just die Oh
[Music]
[Applause]
Boros former ring fine let's do this way
all right why why just wait let me part
of
thank you guys Oh get out of me I kicked
you you realize how unfair that is right
all right I don't understand this don't
touch the syringes so just don't move Oh
Oh God
oh okay oh this is even worse you're
just watching oh wait you're supposed to
go the other way this time you guys are
going down probably what are you trying
to kill us both I'll take me with it
don't do it don't do it don't do it the
other one you get a different finally
I'm the [ __ ] dick
and all that music though okay so
anyways that was we're done with this
one forever unless they come out with
awesome new party mode so dick LC yeah I
guess DLC anyway I feel like a lesser
person after that
[Music]